have you been wondering when you'll be
able to catch a miura mew 2 and pokemon
go well it sounds like you'll be able to
do that soon as the antic CEO John Hanke
has teased their arrival I'm Matt this
is a game spot news update and make sure
to LIKE and subscribe so you're the
first to know when you can catch
legendary Pokemon hanky told wired
Germany that we'd seen more of the
legendary Pokemon this year the first
two generations are the only ones
available in the game at the moment so
it's likely we'll see creatures like mu
mu too-hoo and lugia at some point this
year the legendary bird Articuno however
was spotted in some players rosters last
year but it was later revoked by an
antic to keep everything fair pokemon go
has been going strong since its launch
in July last year antik recently
introduced creatures from pokemon gold
and silver to the game and it is said
it's working on training and PvP battles
we'll keep you updated as more new
features and release dates are revealed
but if you're interested in more
Nintendo franchises on portable devices
then check out our video on how to get
the most out of the cooking in Zelda
breath of the wild
[Music]